[Music]
three two one action
hello welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want we
miss you TIFF and this episode is
brought to you by skill shared skill
shares online learning community with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access so you can join the classes and
communities that are right for you
that's right so whether you want to fill
your curiosity creativity or even career
skills share is the perfect place to
keep you learning and thriving they have
super informative classes on things like
film and video music production
animation and much much more
alright so there's a really interesting
one on how to make your videos look more
cinematic with lighting and subject
placement and etc etc so if you're
really trying to get into film
Skillshare is the place for you
or maybe we need to watch it so we can
make our videos look better text true
and which is good because it's
affordable cuz we also losing money so
it's affordable for us also affordable
for you guys especially when you
compared to pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual subscription in less
than $10 a month and because Skillshare
is sponsoring this video you guys get to
set up with you guys get to sign up with
the link in the description and get a
two month free trial that's right
so head over to sk l dot s h slash
roosterteeth to get a two month free
trial use that any months for free sixty
days that's right so in the description
box below please depending on how many
days are on a month it could be sixty
one oh my god
if you have two February's it could be
56 hmm all right now Chris salsa again
what's going on guys
by the way I'm wearing Chris's shirt yes
sir shout out to Joe may appreciate that
you could get it Chris so so dot shot
get your I ain't no [ __ ] T we got a
white and the new black shirt I am NOT a
[ __ ] I'll do a promo - okay so you
could get your hey [ __ ] t-shirt soon
pretty soon gonna happen soon keep your
eye on the hey [ __ ] put it on yo you
got pulled over by a cop and then they
recognized you I saw it on your inside
it was it was it was uh it was Jesus
like definitely haven you hooking me up
Wow so we so buzz was kind enough to
invite the Latinas of the crew me and
TIFF and then we had an extra ticket so
we invited Stacy boom fans uh and then I
was like oh yeah girls night so I was
like hey babe I'm gonna take your cards
it's rs7 and it's like [ __ ] let me let
me just stop look can I just stop the
story for a second here Joe because she
was very humble very modest let me just
use drop the car and ammo dude
Jim but its parts car humble that is
[ __ ] him picks me up in my dinky
little apartment pull I thought she was
pulling up in the Tesla she comes up in
this like slate grey Audi [ __ ] nicest
[ __ ] I'm glad she didn't bring that
piece-of-shit Tesla I get in the car
she's got like this little hi-hat bra
with those big old titties out in that
tight stomach and his camo pants and
she's kicked out and she's like hey and
I'm like what the [ __ ] am i gay and she
just like she I'm surprised she wasn't
smoking a cigarette and chewing gum at
the same time like we get out of the car
and she like gets and I mean like when
Gio gets up she just keeps going
she's got like stomach out camo pants on
she's like hey bows and I'm like hi yeah
but yes you I digress keep going what
happened oh I see so you had to start
the story back I had to like yeah I like
I like that color coloring the coloring
book dude yeah because you're my outie
no no no Geo showed up [ __ ] big dick
walking tall in we're gonna have big
guys stick around
yeah dude she did he is sorry TIFF and
Stacey don't get you I might have to
like cut in as you tell your sword
yeah cartridge bags cut hose doesn't
even mention you another story yeah it
was just you know yeah so we we go to
this pods mana concert the concert ends
so Luke you said my mom's calling mana
okay right I do now huge they're [ __ ]
huge rockin espanol exactly so they're
huge they're lettuce bang yeah so the
continents at the Quran 11:00 11:30 wait
let me just jump in here we're gonna
want to go into this show she was like
hey don't worry Bo's if anyone asks
you're Dominican and I was like I was
like Bose I'm like you're gonna fit
right in no one's even gonna question
that there's this black girl in the
content that's literally verbatim well
guess what Gio was wrong because
everyone looked at me like I had a gun
no look at you because you were wearing
so [ __ ] tight ass [ __ ] little
black pant pretty kind of see-through
and her ass was popping dude I seen
those see-through pants like that's why
they were in your butt doesn't I got a
perky boy you bro why don't my Instagram
shameless plug yeah and there's that of
the pants with the same but look there
were just quite a few people there that
looked at me like I didn't belong and I
was I think they were looking at your
like how see you she said nah nah dawg
you're being humble [ __ ] no it was
create racism when there's no racism and
that's fun but it's sexism if anything
why I was I thought we were all the same
I thought we were gonna fit in and there
was just one leave they kept looking at
me like yeah cuz it's your Buckley she
was like I need to take a mental [ __ ]
picture so I could tell my [ __ ]
plastic surgeon I want that ass okay
sorry G okay thank you
that way it doesn't feel good hug right
pose so then now think 11:30 I don't
think I've ever looked at a small black
American and been like oh no I'm
threatened if I like bows like bows
looking like Barbie doll looking like
[ __ ] mini little waist
meanwhile we're like we're at the
concert and I'm struggling to figure out
what's happening but at one time he said
with a bubble butt like oh she's
probably packing a gun in there well
they [ __ ] it like there was no
English at all in life but at one point
he says like Manos he Brussels or
something and I was like that's right
though right I was in your hands okay so
now it's you live at 30 I'm the
designated driver so I'm like completely
100% sober everyone else is a little bit
lit and like there's like a little bit
buzzed so then I was like oh I got to
show these [ __ ] with this cars about
so to the freeway it's like a
residential street but it's not like the
like two lanes it's for lien so it's
like a really wide street that's a
completely dead like there's no one on
the street so I'm like I'm just gonna
floor it a little bit cuz it goes like
humble geo disappears zero to 60 I'm
hype about this car though it goes zero
to 60 and how fast I'm a pilot
give us the specs part three in for a
sec well there's like people in the car
now so it's different okay right three
or four seconds it's like no one's in
the car you know when the car drives
itself you go way faster so then I read
it Barton it goes fast okay it goes fast
like floored it and then all the girls
are like Ryan like we're listening to
music really loud the windows are down
and we're like
and I'm like driving uh and then and let
me just say this car it's so smooth
because my broke ass I don't know if
anyone else has ever had hoop the
anxiety
we're like if you're driving for more
than 30 minutes you're like this
[ __ ] my breakdown didn't slow
down for a little bit relax well I mean
let me rest the belt right dude this
[ __ ] was so smooth
I didn't even realized that we were
going sorry Geo 105 I had no army on a
residential no we were it just took off
and then I stopped like I was it was not
a consistent you know it's smooth it was
very smooth so then now I'm like
catching I'm like gonna make a left turn
because the freeways like I could see it
in corner of my eye I'm about to make a
left turn I catch the beginning of a
yellow light I'm like cool it's my time
to go so I take it mid yellow light the
[ __ ] sirens turn ah B yeah and I'm
like oh [ __ ] man okay so I immediately
pull over a cop in an SUV gets out and
he like taps on the back window and he
makes the girls in the backseat because
it's Bo's and TIFF in the backs tasting
the front clearly I'm driving he taps on
the window to make them put the windows
down and then he looks and he's like
with his like maglite and [ __ ] he's like
searching in Cizek whoa we got four
girls in here huh I was like [ __ ] man I
hate LAPD like we're gonna get [ __ ]
harassed so then he looks at us and he's
like still searching our feet and [ __ ]
he's probably just checking you out as
long as he can check to make sure buzz
had a gun no actually what he did was he
he said ladies take you man get out of
the car I was on the sidewalk behind me
- I'm just kidding no that's not true so
then he goes so I noticed that you guys
have a lot of tattoos and I'm like I'm
like but they're not gang I know he
knows this but at this time I'm like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] but I'm like it's not
gang related or anything he goes I know
I know he's like oh where are you guys
going why did he even bring it [ __ ] I
know right and I'm gonna pick you all up
yeah he hasn't even told this yet let's
try to have sort of conversation and
she's our sign so then he goes up and
then he goes uh where are you guys like
where are you where you were do you live
or something like cuz I want to come
hang out know like kind of searching or
whatever it is her license
yeah I think on that yes because I mean
you're not gonna talk about the [ __ ] you
pulled me over here I can ask me for
license registration so then he goes
you're headed back to Monterey Park and
I'm like wait why would you guess that
he's been [ __ ] with you cuz he's a fan
uh wait so then um and then I was like
why would you guess that and he goes I'm
like nobody knows that city and then
he's like Oh cuz I ran your plates ha I
ran your plates so he's doing this job
yeah he's doing his jobs you're supposed
to type in him before you even come out
because it in case they're a felon they
pull a gun on yours yeah yeah so then he
goes he's he says then he goes can I see
your license okay so I have my m1 for
those of you guys that don't know it's
that just means that you can ride a
motorcycle so then I gave it to him and
that's the first thing he calls out he's
like oh you have your motorcycles
license huh uh so you like the need for
speed huh and I'm like god dammit he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so he's like talking
about how how much I like going fast the
way to fail with women by the way so
then he goes was a bulge of his pants
key and tighter now at this point
there's two SUV a [ __ ] cop car so
that's going on I don't know did he call
it in chlorophyll hawkgirl's cause
over there like Bruce and then he tells
his partner right he's like hey he's
like hey oh whatever his name was like
hey come here
check this out we got a movie star on
our hands and I was like yo this guy I'm
like wait does he know like the way he
was behaving I'm like I don't think so I
think you just make me a stupid joke and
he goes love it come on check it out so
he's like you didn't look what I got
that's what he said he's like checking
something maybe just look you up on
Instagram after looking at your license
will get that right so then he goes he
goes yeah man he's like we're about to
catch her like in her next movie sudden
his friend comes or whatever he's like
oh he's like is that Gino like the cop
is like like like his jaw drops really
funny yeah like your movie so he's like
oh [ __ ]
geo Antoinette want this partner was
like oh my god I follow her husband and
and and I follow her and then he leans
into the car he's like oh my god by the
way you have such a cute baby and
partners jaws like we do someone's
[ __ ] with me I started this big and
all the girls were [ __ ] yelling in
the car we were drunk and like howling
cuz then he pulled up your Instagram
yeah yeah they do Powerball Brigade and
like there's like a dope mega fan guys
yeah he said he's like I'm a super fan
man he's like you can't give them a
ticket like you can't do oh he was like
I was like big [ __ ] in and all it was so
satisfying yeah and then yeah and then
he's like nah he's like I don't believe
it pull it up pull it up he's telling me
to pull it up but then his partners like
already had it right like showing you my
Tiger pictures he's showing all my
instagram pictures and [ __ ] and the guy
like the first stop was just like in
disbelief completely and then I was like
oh can I take a picture oh my god can we
cut in here with like a little footage
because I have the video of them looking
at your Instagram you recorded it in it
was like it was like the most part like
the stars align so perfectly at that
moment I could die at that very so how
did you feel at the moment not not just
about the cop like of getting you know
he messed up this whole bit but whenever
they goes is that geo or at that moment
you're like we're good yeah absolutely
lutely like the way he came in to like
side bus I was like oh were you like at
any moment your weren't you were like
I'm so glad I did those food challenges
video yeah you're like that moment would
David slap me during the Wolverine
[ __ ] know what's so worth it man this
moment right here did like shut down his
bid and it forget out of it what's the
most satisfying moment at that moment or
when Bart said I swore up and down he
didn't wear a vest
whatever I damn well yeah was the best
thing oh man
okay so Bart he swears he has the best
memory in the world to me first I'm
going to be my memories no better nurse
what mine is way better but anyway so
then we were helping tip in case because
they were gonna go to Iceland they
needed gear cuz it's obviously cold out
there it's all selling him okay cuz I
don't know what to buy I'm like hate
case you could just wear whatever bart
war he had a jacket he had a flannel he
had a vest over that and Bart swore up
and down he's like I would never wear
this I've never worn a vest I would know
he's just naturally a hot person I would
never wear a dress vest while my body
being cold my arms hot very moment cuz
literally like four five minutes before
that cursor you never knew that you
owned the van showing tip I was showing
the exact outfit he was wearing like
before case he had even got there so
when I heard him say that it was like
angels were like singing in my crotch of
it and like I was no longer in REI I was
like in heaven and everything was like a
cloud and my phone just started blowing
the phone was like it's time did you
milk it did you go all really you did it
wherever yeah but it made sure I make
sure people around me hurt I made sure
tippy you milked it huh I was like Oh
Billy you don't know what a [ __ ] vest
therefore you are similar similar
feeling moment they got you and then
you're just like oh this next guy was
gonna send you flying some adjectives
kind of sent your [ __ ] somewhere on
fire yeah it was good that's a good
question I don't know but yeah that was
my pulling over story that's fun that's
[ __ ] hilarious awesome
and I just took a group picture well
partners other partners nor was it just
one huge and also honestly the cops were
mad [ __ ] shell because a couple of
them DM dose after bailing yo you made
our night like yeah
like scrolling I thought like it was
just like you're on set or something
because what you're wearing you had like
they come like the camo and you knew
with the cops next you I thought it was
a whole like like scene think a sketchy
our dealers no dude literally actually
happy that [ __ ] was mad that's called
that's called hot privilege like you
know what it's it's celebrity prep
exactly because the original guy was
like oh they're hot but they for this
and then they're not hot enough for this
ticket I'm gonna [ __ ] right the first
Mike he was like what maybe my age or a
little bit he just doesn't you just
didn't know yeah I mean but yeah that is
you don't really know but the other guy
looks really young I feel like he was
like maybe early 30s
yeah it was really nice we had a nice
girls night and then after that the wind
got some jack-in-the-box do you bottle
saw jack-in-the-box pulls up with her
expensive s car it takes you to
jack-in-the-box
dude I just tell you the cartoon it was
one and it's not my car it's his car we
went back to Stacy's and we all had [ __ ]
Tesla don't forget it I can't even
afford gas exception for having a moment
of like getting saved off of like being
recognized from so I was working at all
deaf and I was living in I live in all
Monrovia so saving gas I was riding the
train now I don't know I forgot my
wallet so I started like catch me if you
can type of thing just hopping into
these trains so on the way back it
worked it worked getting to work but
then on the way back home that was like
the hard workers everybody's getting off
in the security is heavy and like these
and on the train station stuff and so at
um the Union Station it was that that
was the one that I really I knew I
couldn't get past and I'm sitting here
like looking I'm like damn man like
they're really like there's a line you
can't pass you got a beep your your car
to stuff I don't my wallet I can't even
afford to get you know a thing so I'm
standing right there by the ATM like the
card
atiim and I see that they got the
security guy he's coming up to me
because he saw that I was kind of like
pacing right there I was like oh man
like I already know it's gonna be a
whole thing like do you have your
situation and he goes hey bro you're on
roast me and I'll death and I had that
same moment of like could I remember
that everybody that score me roasted to
[ __ ] shreds on roast me so I know
that was that was a tear web so but I
was like yes I wasn't roast and it was
like and I was like oh thank you for
Levin he looks like feels like so I'm so
probably you get any like very headed
that so I was like I'm very try to let
him know like bro I'm trying to just get
on this train man I don't have [ __ ]
he'll just like off road trip man like
he's kind of looking around he was like
he gave me like like he gave me like his
work things what's it to be pissed yeah
he was just like yeah do you think Berle
like I got cheat on your stuff that's
really nice and I was like cool like
yeah yeah it was a cool like sit tight
yeah Mongoose to be known somehow I feel
like I would end up getting a ticket
because they know my material you didn't
even do anything illegal but I'm just
gonna [ __ ] make something up at the
bottom of the ticket they right
[Music]
[Music]